soon the government will exert  unprecedented control over what  California doctors can say to their  patients about covet 19. we got to stop  the disinformation pipeline essentially  it puts the CDC in the same room with  the doctor and the patient Governor  Gavin Newsom signed ab2098 into law this  September and starting in the New Year  doctors who disseminate what the state  defines as misinformation or  disinformation related to the SARS Cove  to coronavirus can face disciplinary  action by the California medical board  including being stripped of their  licenses these are doctors who are  licensed Physicians who carry the same  license as I do who provide legitimacy  to disinformation is essentially ends  your ability to combat bad ideas put out  by public health because you have this  looming power over you that essentially  can end your career